I was using like it has like the liquid
on the bottom and like the roll-on ball
on the top one of the crew members on
stranger things was like that smells
like my deodorant it was one of like the
girls on so I was like that is me and
it's my dear agq I'm Finn apart and
these are my essentials from home
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay so these are Air Jordan ones I got
them last year they are my favorite shoe
I've ever worn they're just so
comfortable and they fit my feet really
really well it's got like good ankle
support here I also wear bands and stuff
and I wear all different kinds of shoes
no I just sneak your head or anything
but yeah yeah I definitely have a few I
have Nike dunks that are actually I just
got rid of because they were literally
falling apart this is my skateboard I
like to travel everywhere with it I've
been like riding a skateboard since I
was like seven years old because I've
been doing it for so long like super
passionate about it and know a lot of
skateboarders I have immersed myself in
years of skate culture and stuff and
filmed and done stuff yeah I think I
would consider myself a skateboarder at
heart definitely there are tricks I can
do and I could definitely ride my skill
level on a skateboard is just enough to
where I can kind of keep up I'm learning
board slides right now as you can see
from this it's for Louie Lopez's face
but I love riding and I it's super part
of me and I love traveling with with a
skateboard because it makes me feel very
free riding a skateboard these are just
like the default Apple headphones
I honestly could not live without them
because I'm constantly listening in
music when I'm traveling in the car on
the plane everywhere so it is very
important for me to have headphones I
listen to like a bunch of my friends
bands and listening a lot to like King
gizzard the lizard wizard and Skaggs and
I'm listening to this song by the Alessi
brothers called sea bird which is
awesome I listen to a lot of comedy
podcasts but mostly music okay
so this is a Focusrite Scarlett this is
an interfaces for music my travel
everywhere with it so I can record music
on the go I love recording and mixing
stuff and learning how to do it all
myself like record music and stuff so
this is very helpful and it's small and
it's lightweight you can put in your
suitcase and there's like little
individual plugins for patch cords and
stuff and headphones over here and then
many outputs back here and stuff so it's
super easy and fun to do so I've been
using this for a long time and I love it
it's really it's a really great mixer
super user-friendly and easy to use and
you can plug in your headphones here so
I love using it my guitar I travel with
this thing everywhere this is kind of a
newer addition this is a Gibson
I got it in Tokyo Japan in December I
just it sounds incredible and I kind of
just use it on everything this is my
kind of favorite guitar that I own right
now it's kind of an old military guitar
I was in Japan and and in Japan they
really treat their things very well
especially guitars and so when I went to
a guitar store I kind of saw this thing
and I started playing it and it was like
it felt like it was brand new even
though it was from the 60s
so yeah just amazing condition and super
beautiful sounding I'm glad I got it
where I got it and when I got it
this is my film camera I also got in
Japan
my friend Eric steal Berg who's a DOP
was the DOP on ghostbusters he was
shooting a lot with this on set and I
kind of was very interested in it and he
let me use it and I just kind of fell in
love with it there's so user-friendly
and just pick it up and it's exactly
it's a point-and-shoot but it's kind of
like the Cadillac of point shoot so I'm
glad glad I into that again getting this
it's a very great camera I like shooting
people mostly in portraits I like doing
portraits a lot this is deodorant
I travel with it everywhere so that I
feel and smell fine because I travel a
lot this is women's deodorant I think
I've been using women's deodorant a lot
recently
it just works better on me I have no
idea why but this this one I've been
using isn't the one I usually use this
one it's like I got like randomly at a
drugstore and it smells like
pepto-bismol so you know have you like
started using Cologne
oh no I don't like that stuff I you know
I understand when people use it you know
Charley Heaton like just smells amazing
he's got this like cologne he uses all
the time but it's just not my thing
yeah I never was a big spray-on dude
either my brother was though so I I feel
like the smell of acts brand deodorant
it's just like burned into my brain this
is a European ps4 that I got I love
traveling with it I played video games a
lot I'd watch blu-rays a lot and it's
kind of my preferred way of watching
movies I'm a big blu-ray guy I collect
like I've been buying a lot of like
Criterion Collection blu-rays because
they just look incredible and I mean
obviously I'm not like a guy that's like
only blu-ray is dude like no I watch
Netflix and Hulu and TV and stuff but I
love also watching Classic Movies on
on blu-ray I've been playing um war zone
I didn't call duty like Battle Royale
and kind of just whatever piques my
interest or whatever this is my other
central my computer I do everything on
it and it photos I write like I that's
what I do I want to write screenplays I
want to be a filmmaker so write
everything I record all my music on this
it is very very central to me to have
this I have a writing partner and
writing a slasher movie right now it's
kind of we're gonna think of that so
kind of call me slasher so we're
interested in those kind of movies right
now so so this is an iPhone 7 I've had
it since the gatlin something came out
which is like 2017 obviously I love
keeping I need to keep in contact with
people constantly when I'm traveling you
know I talked to a lot of people on it I
record all my auditions on this yeah
it's very very essential to me is the
phone okay yeah so these were my
essentials
thanks everyone so much for watching and
please stay safe out there